Hola qué tal si se trata de un documento
muy difícil también y farragoso porque
hace largos desarrollos vinculados con
la decisión que tomó el tribunal de
condenar a Cristina Fernández de
kirchner y a los otros condenados en
esta causa hay el eje puesto entre otras
cosas en los vínculos entre Lázaro báez
el empresario beneficiado por la obra
pública en Santa Cruz y la familia que
es vínculos comerciales entre ellos por
ejemplo para dar cuenta de que había
intereses comerciales compartidos esa es
una parte bastante larga del desarrollo
de estos fundamentos me gustaría también
señalar algo algo clave que tiene que
ver con que ahora se abre una nueva
etapa hay diez días hábiles para que
todas las partes presenten apelaciones
ante la casación penal que es la segunda
instancia judicial y luego de que pase
casación Más allá de lo que decida se
vuelve a abrir una nueva instancia y
podría llevar esta causa la Corte
Suprema de Justicia de la nación
hablemos ahora en el área un poco sobre
las repercusiones que hubo al momento
sobre todo del arco vinculado con
Cristina Fernández de kirchner hubo una
reacción es muy fuerte diciendo que se
trata de un caso de proscripción Por qué
es la sentencia Dice que no puede ocupar
cargos públicos pero hay que hacer una
aclaración importante esto se da además
en un contexto de un año electoral y si
eventualmente ella se quisiera presentar
como candidata a la presidencia lo
podría hacer porque hasta que la
sentencia no estén firme y haya hecho
todo el recorrido judicial hasta la
Corte Suprema no entra en efecto Así que
podría presentarse sin embargo ella ya
ha dicho que no tiene interés en
presentarse a cargos selectivos Así que
no está claro en ese sentido qué es lo
que hará Y qué efecto tendrá Pero
insisto hay un argumento muy fuerte
vinculado con esta idea de proscripción
de la vicepresidenta